YOU TO GO ON. MEMBERS. WE ONLY
HAVE ONE BILL TODAY, SO LET'S
GET IT DONE. BEFORE WE BEGIN,
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD I'M HERE. DODD HERE. WILK
PRESENT. WILK. PRESENT.
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA. HERE.
ASHBY BRADFORD. BRADFORD. HERE.
GLASER GLASER. PRESENT. JONES.
I'M HERE. JONES. HERE. NGUYEN.
OKOBOJI PADILLA. PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO. HERE. ROTH. ROTH.
HERE. RUBIO. CIERTO SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS OKAY. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
A QUORUM. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OUR ONLY ITEM, SB 537. SENATOR
BECKER. YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. I AM THE ONLY THING
STANDING BETWEEN YOU AND DINNER,
SO I WILL KEEP IT BRIEF. I WANT
TO SAY, FIRST OF ALL, I'M
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF MAJORITY
LEADER GONZALEZ. SHE'S MY
COAUTHOR ON THIS. AND JUST FOR A
MOMENT, BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC. WHAT THE WHOLE
POINT OF THIS IS TO MEMORIALIZE
THE VICTIMS OF THE MEXICAN
REPATRIATION PROGRAM. THIS IS
WHERE WE DEPORTED, ONLY TIME
EVER BY PRESIDENTIAL ORDER, OVER
A MILLION MEXICANS AND MEXICAN
AMERICANS, THE ESTIMATES ARE
OVER 60% WERE CITIZENS THAT WERE
DEPORTED STARTING IN THE 30S.
AND THIS WILL CREATE A MEMORIAL,
PAID FOR BY A NONPROFIT THAT WE
WILL CREATE. IT'LL BE ALL
PRIVATE FUNDS TO REALLY PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE THIS AT A TIME WHEN
THERE IS TALK LIKE ACTIVE TALK
OF MASS DEPORTATIONS. I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE THINK IT'S JUST
TALK. IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT THIS DID HAPPEN AND COULD
HAPPEN AGAIN. AND WE HAVE TO
MEMORIALIZE AND THIS IS THE TIME
TO DO IT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? NO. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
IN THE AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE TO
COME UP AND SUPPORT? SEEING NONE
ANY OPPOSITION, WE'LL TURN TO
THE MEMBERS. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR ROTH. ANY DISCUSSION?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION? IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN DODD.
AYE. DODD AYE. WILK AYE. WILK
AYE. ARCHULETA. Ã. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. GLASER AYE. GLASER. AYE.
JONES. JONES. AYE. NGUYEN OKOBO.
OKOBO OKOBO. AYE. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO FIORENTINO. AYE.
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. CIERTO. I.
SMALLWOOD EXCUSE ME. MEMBERS,
CAN YOU HOLD ON A SECOND? WILK.
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU. WITH
THE BILLS OUT, THAT'S 11. THAT'S
11 ZERO WILL KEEP THE ROLL OPEN.
I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THIS IS MY LAST GEO COMMITTEE
HEARING THAT I'LL BE CHAIRING.
UNLESS THEY THROW SOMETHING YET
OUR WAY. ONE MORE TIME. AND WE
ALL KNOW THE POSSIBILITIES OF
THAT HAPPENING MAY BE STRONG.
MAYBE NOT, BUT I WANTED TO THANK
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
SURE, AND I WANTED TO THANK MY
GEO STAFF. FELIPE LOPEZ, THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT, AND BRIAN
DUKE. WHERE ARE YOU, BRIAN?
STAND UP. BRIAN HE WON'T STAND
UP. AND MONIQUE GRAHAM, THANK
YOU VERY, VERY MUCH. WHILE I'M
AT IT, JUST AS A POINT OF
PRIVILEGE, MY CHIEF OF STAFF,
SIOBHAN, AND MY CAPITAL DIRECTOR,
LES FONT, ARE BOTH HERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU ALL VERY, VERY MUCH
FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT AND
DILIGENCE DURING THE YEAR. AS
WE'VE AND PAST YEARS AS WE'VE
HAD THIS MEETINGS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE'LL KEEP THE ROLL
UP, PLEASE. WELL SINCE WE'RE
MEMBERS AND THEY'RE MOSTLY GONE,
WE WANT TO JUST SAY I
COLLECTIVELY, I THINK I'M GOING
TO SPEAK FOR ALL OF US SO WE CAN
GET OUT OF HERE. BUT JUST THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
DILIGENT AND JUST SUCH A GREAT
CHAIR. SO JUST PUBLICLY, WE WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE AND HOW WELL YOU'VE
LED US INTO THIS WONDERFUL JUST
CONCLUSION OF YOUR TENURE. SO
THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE YOU.
YES. BIG ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO
HIM AND THE SECRETARY. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY NGUYEN. PADILLA. PADILLA.
AYE CUEVAS. IT'S 12. IT'S 12.
BATHROOM BATHROOM. SPECIAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OH, WELL,
IT'S HARD TO.
HOLD ON, HOLD ON. SIR, WE'RE
STILL. YEAH, WE'RE STILL IN. IF
YOU WANT TO COME BACK AND THEN.
IT'S ALL GOOD. THANK YOU. YOU'RE
WELCOME. THANKS. MR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY Ã. ASHBY.
AYE. NGUYEN. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
THAT'S 13. THANK YOU. THAT'S 13.
YEAH. YOU KNOW, AT THE END, I
DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING ABOUT TEN
MORE. I APOLOGIZE. ALL RIGHT.
YOU DID A GREAT COLLABORATOR THE
WHOLE TIME. I REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THAT YOU'VE DONE FOR THE
PEOPLE. AND WHAT IS. YEAH. THANK
YOU. FOR THAT INCLUDES BUSINESS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. MR. YES.
THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS,
BEFORE THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE. THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.